holland trauert um 5 rettungsschwimmer
die männer zwischen 22 und 38 jahren sie
starben in den fluten der nordsee
sie galten nicht als leichtsinnig oder
übermütig sie galten als erfahrene
schwimmer mehr als hundert trauernde
standen am dienstagmittag an der
niederländischen küste und suchten nach
der antwort auf die frage nach dem warum
drama vor der niederländischen küste
am montagabend haben heftiger wind oder
eine starke strömung in schwenningen
eine gruppe surfer in not gebracht
nach angaben der küstenwache kunden
mindestens 7 der sportler nicht mehr aus
eigener kraft den strand erreichen
sie mussten von rettungskräften aus der
nordsee geholt werden
zwei von ihnen konnten nur noch tot
geborgen werden ein weiterer kam in ein
krankenhaus
die suche nach weiteren vermissten
musste gegen 23 uhr wegen dunkelheit
erst einmal abgebrochen werden
nach der wiederaufnahme am
dienstagmorgen gegen 6 uhr an die
rettungskräfte dann drei weitere
lieblose surfer im wasser und fassbar
die opfer sollen erfahrene
rettungsschwimmer gewesen sein
das berichtet der telegraph offenbar
waren sie von den hohen wellen und einer
dicken schneeschicht auf dem wasser
erfasst worden
am unglücksort ist bild reporter michael
engelberg michael was weiß man über die
unglücksursache gesprochen wird von
wellen schauen scheint tatsächlich ein
großes stück zu dieser tragödie
beigetragen zu haben muss man einmal mit
der kamera auf den schauen
es handelt sich um so eine art schaum
wir gehen davon aus die die experten
gehen davon aus dass es sich dabei um
putins im allgäu annehmen soll
die in verbindung mit meter hohen wellen
tatsächlich einen klebrigen schaut
machen und surfer haben uns gestern
gesagt dass es eventuell so gewesen sein
kann dass der winter schaut und die
hohen wellen
[Applaus]
sehr wahrscheinlich vor die dieser
schaum tatsächlich zumindest teilweise
schuld an diesem unglück welche rolle
hatten das wetter gespielt zur
unglückszeit von jungs eine reizvolle
erfahren super sondern wird nicht vor
die eigentlich dafür aber den leuten zu
zeigen
also sind sie müssen gegen uns gesagt
haben überrascht wird mit schnellen
alleinschuld gründen und alles das muss
nur den konfessionen an diesem
schauplatz um beigetragen haben das ist
dann keine toten
das fatale ist dass noch eine person
nicht gefunden das so gesehen allerdings
konnten sie nicht
deshalb standen ziemlich genau stehen
weiterhin am strand versuchen dieses
unglück weiter zu verarbeiten michael
wie ja verarbeitet denn die
wassersportgemeinschaft dort in der
region dieses unglück
also als mir gestern nachmittag gekommen
sind stand hier wirklich hunderte server
von der ballettschule wurde das surfen
gelernt haben und sich zu gehör nicht zu
diese server gemeinschaft ist eine ganz
verschworene solidarischen minuten also
hier ist jeder für den sport oder weiß
dass er bei uns eine schwierige lage
kommen
in einer brenzligen situation gekommen
ja natürlich auch passiert als medien
etwas und das machen heute alles auch so
fassungslos weil softpro sportwagen und
zahlt keine risiko sind ganz schön
der bürgermeister hat gestern einer von
uns geworden und wir sehen dass es so
einen euro